Hey, I'm Janet. Boom, rod. I am
Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab.
And this next segment began
with a simple question.
Seeing as our topics
before has been limits.
And sure we'd done body when we did the
brain. Oh, we're going to go really big.
Yeah. Yeah. So we called up
Steve Strogatz, mathematician
at Cornell University,
frequent guest on the
show. And we asked him,
are there limits to human knowledge? Yeah.
And his answer sent us on a
little adventure. Um, yeah.
Is there anything that's at the limits
of our knowledge is a question that a lot
of us scientists worry about. And, and uh,
certainly the 20th century taught us
that there are many things that limit our
knowledge. For instance,
that the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
in quantum physics showed us that you
can't know the position and momentum of
a subatomic particle at the same time.
You just can't do it.
It's not a matter of not having good
enough instruments or not being clever
enough. It's just a fundamental
barrier that nature puts in your way.
Um, in logic girdles theorem tells us you
can't prove certain things even though
they're true. So we, there
are all kinds of limits,
but those seem a bit remote
from everyday experience.
And yet I think there are really important
limits on our knowledge that we're
all familiar with.
What I'm thinking of here is our inability
to think about big numbers because
with your fingers you've got 10 you
know, normally. So we're good at 10,
we're barely good at a hundred and
once you start getting to thousands,
millions, billions and trillions,
it gets hazier and hazier.
When you hear now about the trillions
of dollars in the deficit or whatever it
is, the debt, you know, we
don't, that means nothing.
How are you supposed to think
about that? Now when you ask,
why can't we understand the common cold?
But we can put a person on the moon.
It has to do with large numbers, not
just large numbers of numbers. So Steve,
that large numbers of things interacting,
that there are so many genes involved
and so many biochemical reactions
involved, our brains are limited, our
memories are very limited. And so,
um, I worry a little bit that the,
we might be approaching the end of our
ability to have insight into certain
kinds of questions. What Steve Means
by the word insight is not like a,
you found the answer. It's like, that's
like a feeling, right? You like that.
Oh, I get it. Feeling you get when you
really understand the answer. Yeah.
That satisfying feeling that I can see
the reasoning and I can actually feel it
in my bones. That's, that's a
very pleasurable feeling. But, um,
one that we may not
always be able to enjoy.
I mean, you can see the space.
We weren't really quite sure how to feel
about this, but then Steve said, yeah,
don't take my word for it. Talk to these
guys that work down the hall from me.
You'll see we can, we can go right ahead.
Cool. Can you guys introduce yourself?
Tell me who I'm talking to. Yeah.
So, uh, my name is Hod Lipson.
My name is Michael Schmitz.
I'm a phd student and a,
I'm a roboticist and hot and Mike have
developed this thing which does make you
wonder if Steve's right.
It's a computer. Yes.
Actually many a whole tower of computers
that are all grinding away in this
morning calculations.
Actually when you get down to it,
it's just a piece of software,
but they've named it Eureka cause
that's what it was designed to do,
to have you Rica moments. Uh,
maybe a, a kind of simpler example.
And the story of Eureka begins
pretty simply with a pendulum. Okay?
Depending on just one of these things
you see hanging off a grandfather clock,
okay, I've got a regular pendulum
swinging in my mind. Okay?
Swinging left and right now says w
instead of a string connected to ball,
make it a string, connected to a
ball, connected to another string,
connected to another ball, which is
basically like a double pendulum.
The cool thing about this is you just put
it, you, you lift it up and let it go.
And what you'll get says Mike is chaos.
That's really crazy
behavior instead of Nice.
And even now you got random.
It's almost impossible actually try
to predict where the single move.
So what they did was they got a camera
connected it to Eureka and Jessica just
had Eureka Watch this thing.
I mean a move about crazily.
And then they asked the computer
a really simple question,
can you make some kind of sense
out of this erratic behavior?
Like is there something in this
system that always stays the same?
Tell me what about these pendulums
over time is not changing cause with
everything there's gotta be
some kind of logic in there.
So you're looking for
a law, basically I'm,
you're looking for the law of the
double pendulum. Yes. That's the idea.
So Eureka is there watching this pending
numbers about 3:00 AM in the lab is
basically spitting out all of these
different guesses, formulating hypotheses.
It's getting closer and closer.
And then onto the screen pops
this simple formula f equals m.
What is f equals? I mean, is
that actually the [inaudible]?
The law that f equals the May
is Newton's law of motion.
The Isaac Newton that Sir Isaac. To you.
So Basic Law of physics in one of the
greatest discoveries in the history of
human thinking.
Uh,
took it about day 24 hours.
Okay.
But the interesting thing is that it
came up with this thing without knowing
anything about physics,
nothing. That's why we kind of,
we think that this algorithm might be
able to find new laws that we don't know
about yet.
In fact, once word got out about Eureka,
that's when the emails start a couple
emails a day to scientists all over the
place who were like, Hey,
do you mind if we borrow your
robot for what kinds of stuff?
Um,
anything you can think of from trying
to predict behaviors of cows in the herd
to particle physics, to a stock market
and fat. And this is when we get Steve's
point about the limits of insight.
That's when they met this guy.
My name is girl soil girl is a biologist
at the University of Texas Southwestern
Medical Center. He got in touch with hod
when you said, I have this amazing
data, which is single cell dynamics,
meaning he's got this tiny little
things. So simple bacteria, really basic,
and he's been collecting this information
on how it works on its inside,
how things go up and down. Certain
nutrients increase certain nutrients,
decrease over time,
just like a [inaudible].
The thing is in a cell, it's
like a thousands of pendulums.
There's so many part genes turning
on and off, thousands and thousands,
tens of thousands proteins turning on
other genes and nutrients going up and
down. It's this crazy quilt
of complicated feedback.
And you wanted to know inside of this
cell, how are all of these things related.
I mean, we can measure it all, we can see
things going up and down and all that.
But what are the rules? What
are the rules here in this?
He says is the problem for biology.
Biology is one of the least well
understood systems compared to let's say,
chemistry and physics. They're still
lacking the basics. So we said, look,
Mr Robot,
can you tell us what you think are sort
of the important principles governing
this organism and maybe detect
things that were hidden from us.
So he sent us the data
and uh, we analyzed it
and uh, well, OK, let's not let, yeah,
so what happened suddenly
equation starting, popping out
almost immediately the robot
came back to us and said, okay,
here's a set of two equations
that describe your data.
Do you remember by any chance what
the, what the actual equation was? Not,
not that we'd understand it, but just
sort of to hear it said out loud. Yeah,
no, I don't want,
you don't have my rain man skills
developed to that degree yet.
The important thing is that the equation
was telling them things like when this
protein goes up, this other
thing always goes down.
And when that thing goes down, this gene
turns on and there's a loop de loop.
And when he went to his cell to check
all this out, the equation was right.
These equations match the data.
And in fact, they explain new data.
These equations could even predict
with the cell was about to do,
but hold the champagne. There's
just one little problem here.
The formulas checkout, but
we don't know what they mean.
You don't know what they mean. Right?
Meaning they don't know why these
equations work. I why when this goes up,
does that go down? Why when that
goes up, does this go sideways? Why?
I had to first look at this and try
to make sense of it. We said like, oh,
okay, I think we understand. And
we were like, oh maybe we don't.
We think that we're close
to understanding it,
but you know, now we're
in this bizarre situation.
We can't even publish it right now
cause we can't just publish a equation
without explaining it.
So in the end, they're in this awkward
position when they've got the answer,
but they don't have the insight.
And I think it's a preview
of what's the common signs.
The more we turned to with these big
questions, the more they'll give us
answers that we just don't understand.
We'll be faced with this challenge of
having to find ways to get a computer to
explain what it found.
But that will leave us if this really
happens in some weird position as
bystanders where we're, we're
sort of listening to the oracle,
but not really understanding the answer.
Is there gonna be a time when we,
we can't cut it anymore. We've had this,
this window in human history when we
could not just know things but actually
understand them. That is, you could
know why they were true, not just know,
but to know why. And that's a
beautiful moment in human history.
But I feel like it may only be a moment.
Well, I don't really see it quite that,
that sort of sad and dramatic because at
the end there will be simple principles
to describe even the most
complicated of processes.
So you have a bias that prevents you from
feeling the kind of despair that Steve
feels that we were hoping you
would feel. Oh, well I'm, I,
I have a positive outlook, but
I just wondering about the,
we look what we have discovered.
You'll say when you're an old man with
your robot sitting there and address next
to you and the robot will
be holding your hand.
But that will be a cold hand
and Jad and I will be thinking,
I dunno who's the we here. I as well.
I would say we is sort of knowledge.
I'm just thirsty for understanding
and thirsty for knowledge.
Me and the cold hand holding my hand,
we've accumulated and contributed to the
overall understanding of something that
we thought maybe 50 years
ago wasn't possible.
And that would be something
that would make me happy.